the midterms are over we're going to be
counting the votes until we're all along
in the tooth but the midterms are over
so Donald Trump seems to be running
full steam ahead 2024 and he is going
after his chief rival Ron DeSantis
real hard uh president Trump just gave
an interview on news Nation where he
explained why he is so offended that Ron
DeSantis appears to be running
for president Ron is a person I've
always had a decent relationship with
him but when I endorsed him he was he
was gone he was not going to be able to
even be a factor in the race and as soon
as I endorsed him within moments he the
race was over I got him the nomination
he didn't get it I got it because the
minute I made that endorsement he got it
then he ran and he wasn't supposed to be
able to win I did two rallies we had
52 000 people each one and
we ended up he won and I thought that he
could have been more gracious but that's
up to him I like that at the end he says
I'm entirely responsible for Rhonda
Sanders's political career okay the guys
nothing without me and so listen
I thought he should be a little bit
gracious okay but hey look all right I
don't I'm not saying anything here and
and this answer from Trump is a very
good answer to the chief anti-trump
attack right now which is that India's
midterm elections the Trump picks
in the primaries were total losers Trump
has terrible picks in the primaries and
and Trump's answer to that is hey guys
DeSantis was one of my primary picks so
the argument is Trump's picks in the
primaries are terrible and maybe Ron
desantises would be better he says oh
yeah hey get guess who guess who one of
my most prominent primary picks was Ron
DeSantis thank you very much so that
that's his argument here uh then he's
taking to truth social he's not taking
to Twitter he's not on Twitter anymore
but he's taking to truth social and he
says now that the election of Florida is
over and everything went quite well
shouldn't it be said that in 2020 I got
1.1 million more votes in Florida than
Ron D got this year 5.7 million to 4.6
million he goes just asking
it's like you know it's not really
comparable because presidential election
years more people show up to vote than
in the midterm elections but
look I don't think it's a great look for
Trump I think it makes it look like he
is insecure about his ability to win the
nomination Ron DeSantis did not attack
him first and is not attacking him back
if DeSantis were attacking Trump then I
think it would be probably all right for
him but the fact that DeSantis is not
attacking him it doesn't look great for
Donald Trump but I tell you
as always
the the reaction to Trump's statements
and tweets or fake tweets here now the
truth social tweets
I think a lot of it depends on the tone
in which you you hear him
so for instance some of the big
headlines are if you read that truth
social
tweet as I did much better than Ron
DeSantis I got I got 1.1 million he got
four 1.1 million more votes he got he
only got 4.6 million I got 5.7 million
right if you just read it like that then
it seems kind of petulant and annoying
and but if you read it as hey how come
nobody's talking about this you know I
did a lot better I'm just asking you
know if you read it as a joke it's it's
much funnier obviously and it it reads
much differently I'll give you a better
example of this
there was a big headline where it said
Donald Trump says
if candidates win on the mid in the
midterms then he deserves all the credit
but if the candidates lose he deserves
none of the blame can you believe this
do you believe this Donald Trump you
know and so I read that headline and I
said what did he actually say I went to
the clip here's here's what he said
you've endorsed more than 330 candidates
this election cycle tonight win or lose
the results for Republicans
um how much of that will be because of
Donald Trump
well I think if they win I should get
all the credit and if they lose I should
not be blamed at all okay but it'll
probably be just the opposite uh when
they win I think they're going to do
very well I'll probably be given very
little credit even though in many cases
I told people to run and they ran and
they turned out to be very good
candidates you know they've turned out
to be very good candidates but usually
what would happen is when they do well I
won't be given any credit and if they do
badly they will blame everything in me
so I'm prepared for anything but we'll
defend ourselves so it's the same words
that you're reading in the headline but
it's a completely different tone and if
you're watching it on TV you can see
that as Trump's saying that he's got a
little smirk
says oh what's my take on the midterms
here's what I think should happen if
they win I should get all the credit and
if they lose I shouldn't get any of the
blame you know it's going to be the
opposite but I listen my preference
would be that and he's joking he's
joking it's a joke okay and I remember
this in 2016. my friends who were the
most irritated by Trump
and who just were the most befuddled by
Trump are the ones who have are not from
New York have never lived in New York
and don't don't know a lot of New
Yorkers
and the people who kind of laughed at
Trump or Shrugged him off or got a kick
out of him tended to be the New Yorkers
or people who have spent time in New
York okay this is
Donald Trump
is at his core a New Yorker okay and New
Yorkers make jokes and they're Brash and
they use Hyperbole and they speak with
their hands like I am doing right now
and like Donald Trump does and they bust
people's bullions and they they hit
people and they just you know it's just
the way that they are okay and so
this is going to keep up because Donald
Trump seriously wants to be president I
think
Donald Trump rightly understands that
Ron DeSantis is his chief
rival in 2024 and so he's going to keep
dinging him he's going to keep dinging
him now this might this might just turn
people off I've been following a lot of
the commentary on this and a lot of
people are saying look I love Trump I
voted for him twice but enough don't hit
why are you going to hit this good
Republican Governor down in Florida
who's doing great stuff come on get man
it's two years away chill out but Donald
Trump he is who he is he is a New Yorker
he is Brash he's bold he hits he fights
and so that is that is just going to
happen that is just baked in the
presidential race is on we're not done
counting the votes for 2022 but the race
is on okay and for the people who are
saying Trump shouldn't hit DeSantis give
me a break okay Trump is who he is it's
a presidential contest he's going to do
it and and for Donald Trump by the way
who says Ronda Santos shouldn't run
against me I made him he should be
gracious okay give me a break all right
that's insane this is politics we're
talking about the highest office in the
land this is the time that Ron DeSantis
probably has to run if he wants it the
way the Cycles fall all next time he's
probably going to be yesterday's news
and in politics as in comedy timing is
everything so he's going to run I don't
think that he's a he's a bad man for
running against Trump who helped him win
his first race and frankly I don't think
Trump is a bad man for trying to get his
old job back and for running especially
when he's this high up in the polls this
is politics politics is a really tough
brutal business and the guys who do well
in it are really tough guys who can take
a punch I think DeSantis can take a
punch I think Trump can take a punch
they can both throw them as well and
starting most likely next Tuesday with
that announcement at Mar-A-Lago Trump
could surprise us and not announce but
all all the signs are pointing to him
announcing a run that means 2024 is Off
to the Races we've got a very important
conservative lawyer coming on to help us
discuss that that would of course be
Jenna Ellis the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]